little smashing pumpkins in this
morning's eye on earth we're looking at
how climate change is threatening
pumpkins yes even pumpkins fall of
course is when pumpkins shine and
everything from soups and coffee to pies
and fall to core illinois believe it or
not leads the u.s in pumpkin production
growing more than 500 million pounds a
year and that brings in an estimated 200
million dollars in revenue megan claros
traveled to southern illinois to talk to
farmers about the challenges that
they're facing making good morning yeah
good morning to you tony a lot of money
in pumpkins big problems potentially
down the line farmers rely on the
seasonal crop for their livelihood we
spoke to one scientist trying to carve
out a solution to save pumpkins from
climate change's wrath
we have our pumpkin patch wayne searles
is the fifth generation to work this
land at rendelman orchards in southern
illinois
since the 1870s his family has been
planting vegetables
until just a few years ago we are pretty
much dictated by mother nature climate
change has brought about more
precipitation in illinois and more
intense spring rainfall too
the rain in wetter fields forced wayne
and his wife michelle to pivot from
zucchini and cucumbers to pumpkins
you're completely out of the vegetable
business now we're completely out of it
when you're actually down in the dirt
with those vegetables when you made that
decision not to continue growing them
what were you seeing what was happening
to them well we were seeing a lot of
lack of production our production was
basically going down due to various
disease pressures that you would get
from from excessive amounts of rain for
now pumpkins have allowed the searles to
stay in the farming business
capitalizing on america's obsession with
everything fall
each year the u.s produces approximately
1.3
billion pounds of pumpkin and sales of
products that include pumpkin like
yogurt bread and desserts top 1 billion
dollars
but pumpkins are not immune to climate
change
too much rainfall and rising
temperatures can also damage the health
of the crop pumpkins like to be grown at
75 to 85 degrees and we start increasing
temperature that means we have less
production allen walters is a professor
of vegetable science and breeding at
southern illinois university and he's on
a mission to save the future of pumpkins
in illinois
pumpkins are native to
the u.s and mexico so it's really part
of us scientists estimate that by the
end of the 21st century the average
daily temperature in illinois could
increase between 4 and 14 degrees
walters is one of the only scientists
studying the effects of warming
temperatures on pumpkins we need to
start looking further into the future 50
75 100 years what's really going to
happen during that time i'll be long
gone by then but hopefully some of my
pumpkins will still be around walters
crosses different varieties of pumpkins
with optimal characteristics like a
sturdy stem in the hopes he will create
a perfect heat resistant pumpkin we have
the continuity you have it we have the
color you have the color we've got you
got the handle on it this entire hybrid
process can take years but for walters
it's worth it what we're talking about
is trying to save a particular way of
american life
with the help of his research the
searles believe their farm can survive
and thrive but they also know they may
have to make changes as they grow
i'm the fifth generation my family's
been doing this for 150 years
they've adapted so i think hopefully
that we can continue to adapt
walter says he's constantly fielding
calls from farmers all around the
country by the way this is about a
10-year process dr walters is around
halfway through so maybe another four to
five years before any seeds that he's
created will be available hmm all right
protect the pumpkins yeah yeah looking
for a magical pumpkin they can withstand
the heat
yes and it's not easy to do they're
crossing those varieties every year you
know if you weren't concerned about
climate change before they're coming for
your pumpkin spice latte you're gonna be
paying more
pay attention america